das lokal herzlich willkommen meine
damen und herren wir heute zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanal fertig habe
viele videos im amerikanischen raum
gesehen wo leute ihre
weihnachtsgeschenke gezeigt haben und
dabei nicht mir jetzt mittlerweile schon
mehr als eine woche her ist ich bin echt
spät dran ich gerade auf jeden fall her
ich zeige euch einfach mal auch was ich
so alles zu weihnachten bekommen weil
ich meine ich hab sogar gesagt man kommt
auch ohne brad pitt den judoka aus dem
helikopter habe allerdings nicht direkt
an mit den geschenken die ich zu
weihnachten bekommen habe sondern ich
war im urlaub mit meiner familie meiner
schwester meinen eltern und mit jule und
meine schwester hat jule was zu
weihnachten geschenkt hat mich gefragt
was er jude zu weihnachten schenken kann
ich habe gesagt hund also ich sitze also
[Musik]
dass nicht nur das preisschild abgemacht
auf jeden fall gemacht im klosterdorf
kill bill
nadal dieses kleine runde kleiner kisten
von meiner schwester bekommen und dann
hat sie mir ein geschenk gegeben dass
schokolade
das mag eine schublade und ein wenig
blocksberg hörbuch ich mag auch keine
bibi blocksberg danke blocksberg und das
bilde schlittenrennen auf jeden fall
dafür aber ich weiß natürlich die geste
zählt auch ein zweites geschenk gegeben
das zweite geschenk das sie mir
geschenkt hat ist eine tasse mit ihren
anfangsbuchstaben drauf ohne henkel
danke da der geschenk preis das ist ein
geschenk preis natürlich noch damit
nicht genug meine liebe luxuriöser hat
natürlich auch noch für meinen eltern
geschenke vorbereitet und das was die
meinen vater geschenkt hat das seht ihr
jetzt aber hat von sarah ein pass
bekommen was sie kaputt gemacht hat bei
einer party zuhause zerstört ein glas
wein einschenken körper zu weihnachten
klasse
meine mutter mir geschenkt gegeben hat
mir mal geschenkt
es ist ein strauß doch nichts und ich
das immer ich sehe darin mit mir und wir
brauchen namen für den die habe ich auf
jeden fall bekommen also ohne diese
brille hier hat tatsächlich auch einen
strauß bekommen also den strauß ob ich
bekommen
unter all dem wirrwarr in größerem
stress bekommen
warum werden größeren strauß begonnen
doch nicht doch erstens dass gegen
diesen hingewiesen wäre also sollen
kleiner tipp von wegen wir kaufen uns
der strauß farben aber nicht einfach nur
so
diesen strauß bekommen wollen wir nun
allerdings zu dem was ich hole mir
geschenkt hat das waren einerseits
flippers der hausschuhe mit unglaublich
krass gemütlichen schafsfell drin und
sie haben auch noch eine karaffe
geschenkt also eine whiskey kaffee
apfelsaft kommt dabei nicht sieht
einfach mega geil aus und naja es ist
eigentlich nur eine flasche aber wollte
ich schon immer haben weil ich finde
dass ist mega cool aussieht meine oma
hatten die hamburger hafen curry
geschenkt das ist ein scharfes curry
kasse scharfe sachen aber ich weiß das
ist auch noch gut gemeint und sie hatten
ja noch nicht viel geld geschenkt
allgemein auf us und opas schenken so
viel geld es ist müssen die doch gar
nicht tun das habe ich auch noch
bekommen
age die längen hand and nail treatment
für kurze zeit zum vorteilspreis auf
jeden fall so die geschenke die ich an
heiligabend bekommen habe das beste
daran wirklich dieser dieser strauß der
sieht aus wie sonst die finde ich
sowieso bernhard aber schreibt ihm etwa
gegen abend für dieses kleine 4 und die
kommentare schreibt nachdem es in die
kommentare was das weiterkommen haben
das interessiert mich halt heftig das
war auch früher immer so die starre
behalten wenn man zurück in der schule
war so hey was hast du bekommen hast du
bekommen hast du bekommen hast doch die
kommt da bekommen und mir nun allerdings
meine damen und herren zu dem haupt
geschenk was sarah und ich bekomme jetzt
die direkten der nicht so einfach ist
aber ein packers sind zu heiß
das ist rico ricco war das alpaka dass
ich nehmen durfte und ich rum schön
durfte nico war übrigens ziemlich
verfressen wasserparadies ende rico und
das alpaka von sana hieß in wien unlock
und
sind wir halt rumgelaufen am fuße der
zugspitze
wenn wir mit ein paar castrum gewandert
normaler tag
der gast in meinen rebecca harry co
genau das war so sehen wir hatten da
denkt jeder einheit pacar und sind
einfach unglaublich
die größten volltrottel und hat sogar
einmal kurz mit mir geredet ja das hat
mich wirklich geliebt aber sage auch
nicht was allerdings nicht alleine bei
dieser wanderung sondern es sind noch ca
fünf bis zehn andere leute mitgelaufen
und einer von diesen anderen mitläufern
hatte sondern echt komische sadeh vorne
sieht ganz viele haare vor seinen augen
ist die ganze überall gegen gelaufen die
bereits gesagt hieß das alpaka ja
namenlos das war ein helles alpaka mainz
hatte so braunes fell und das alpaka war
halt so wenn man ihm keine
aufmerksamkeit geben hat das gemacht
habe eines ihnen sogar video das alpaka
vom sache einfach losgelaufen ist daraus
ein paar kein echtes bescheuert sind
passt ja ja da war man schon deutlich
entspannt hat und dann mal wieder am
bahnhof angekommen und mussten uns von
den verschiedenen was ist das schön hier
mit den bergen mit meinen hobbys oder
oder mit euch
das finde ich echt waren sie mit den
ohren
es geht wirklich mein absolutes
highlight setzte geschenk das ich mehr
oder weniger mir selbst geschenkt habe
es ist traurig ich hab mir selbst zu
weihnachten geschenkt wo ich glaube da
hinten kommt ein sturm das hier war eine
alte blocking kamera die ist mir
allerdings auf die tat irgendwie hin zu
gefallen und auch ins meer und dann auf
den boden
ich gehe ich gut mit kameras und ich
habe auf jeden fall seine neue glocken
kamera gekauft das die mit der ich
gerade filme der focus funktioniert
super die kamera habe ich mir gekauft
weil ich mir gedacht hey ich möchte mal
wieder mehr blogs machen und macht
gerade oder sie die komisches mit dem t
shirt ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
für das paket kommt bald maxi diskurs
mit dem kaktus der aufnahme in den link
ja du kleine senke wer ist flop
aber ich hab viele videos gesehen wo
leute ich ihre weihnachtsgeschenke
gezeigt haben und ich meine so grantig
bekommen am untermain instagram fotos
aus dem urlaub haben viele geschrieben
hast du nen alpaka 2000 bekommt ein
alpaka wanderung leider ich habe auch
gemeint ist eigentlich schon zehn tage
her doch ich habe irgendwie trotzdem ja
ich habe keine idee und bevor ich mich
jetzt hier vor seines denn die kamera
gesetzt hätte irgendwie dachte ich mir
hätte ich meine neue blocking kamera
wollte mein block sehen oder guckt euch
das gar nicht nur knie man das auf jeden
fall mal einen daumen hoch für dieses
video da wenn ihr bock auf mehr blogs
habt und schreibt mir unbedingt mal in
die kommentare wie dieser das traurige
ist der sieht mir halt echt unfassbar
ähnlich hier an beide so komplex dass
aus der haare und beide gerade was ich
glaube ich bin strauß schneider auf
jeden fall wenn die kommentare wie
dieser kleine strauß hier heißen soll
die mit zu ändern werden was du zu
weihnachten bekommen hast das
interessiert mich weil ich habe auch
twitter einige touristen sehen wir heute
mal zwei handys zu kommen im fernsehen
computer drei bildschirme ja es geht bei
weihnachten nicht um die geschenke also
ja kann man freut sich trotzdem über
geschenke aber es geht nicht primär um
die geschenke
ich habe gerade voll karacho meiner hand
hier gegen gehauen hat es werden blaue
flecken die beiden würden das video in
der stadt jetzt auf jeden fall beendet
meine damen und herren es euch gefallen
hat mir gesagt dass gerne daumen hoch
das schreibt das einen kommentare was
gesagt und jetzt ist mein einziger
freund übrigens
[Musik]